What does your wife do, if
you don't mind me asking?
Not at all.
She's a Jesuit priest.
Oh, okay.
(laughing)
All right, come on, Jesuit.
My wife, when I met
her, was in advertising.
She was an advertising executive,
and then when she got
pregnant with our first child,
I think, she started, I
think was around then,
she started working on, her
real passion is writing.
So she's been writing plays.
She works with different
playwriting organizations
and theater groups,
and she's a dramaturge,
which means she reads other
people's plays and tries
to help them and gets, gets involved a lot
in independent theater,
and she works really hard,
very proud of her.
She's a really smart.
It's hilarious to see that,
my bed stand and her bed stand.
Hers, you know, mine is always like,
some cheesy historical murder mystery,
and then her, hers is just like the great,
you know, Aristotle and Plato and all the,
just the, you know, Beckett,
all the great playwrights,
and she's constantly
reading that stuff and I get
really intimidated because
she's, she's really brilliant.
She's really smart and creative.
Oh, I really like listening to people talk
about their significant
others because you can't
really see it, but I could see it.
Your like, face changed
when you talked about her
and that's like, so magical.
It's truly a dream,
and that's what I want.
I want my face to change when I talk
about somebody that I love.
I want their face to
change when someone's like,
"Oh, who are you dating?"
And it's like,
"Oh, Nicole, she's so wonderful."
That, it's so magical.
It was really lovely to see.
Well, you know, I would
tell you, I, this can sound
very West Coast and
granola-y and spiritual
and I'm, I'm so not that
person but what I have come
to believe and I actually,
I talk to a lot of the women
in my office about this.
I, I tell them like, my
big thing, when I talk
to younger women that work on the staff,
if they ever, you know,
holiday party or whatever,
and they're talking
about dating and how hard
it is right now, I just, my
big thing is don't settle.
Like, do not settle.
Don't settle.
I did not settle, and
there's not a day in my life
when I don't think, oh
man, I, I've made good.
I've had good ideas and
bad ideas, but 19 years ago
I made the exact right
call, and that's the way
you want to feel, and that's what you,
you just keep going 'til
you find that person.
Like, that's, that's what you deserve.
You deserve that, and,
and you do, you really do.
Thank you, Conan.
I think I deserve it too.
You do.
So, so I think that's why,
and I think what's gonna,
what helps you so much is you
really do know what you want
and you're a very confident,
attractive person.
So that's just going to happen.
It's just a question of when.
It's going to happen when
you're not thinking about it.
You know, you're going to be at a CVS
and you're going to bump into somebody.
That's when it's, that's when it happens.
That's what people say.
They say, when you're
not thinking about it,
you're not looking for
it, that's when it happens
but I'm always thinking
about it and looking for it.
(laughing)